[Musique]
voici une recette de crêpes assez
extraordinaire signé pierre repp oui je
vous dois une confidence bien sûr j'ai
eu l'occasion de montrer que j'avais des
facilités d'équitation et des facilités
des kilos sion des collections des lots
q sion mais j'avais mot vaulion dingue
j'ai un violon grindes havre 1-1 dada et
mandada c'est la cuisine c'est surtout
l'attaqué privé surtout l'apathie et
triple appelé gâteau oh ça c'est pas
pour moi remarqué gens mangent pas faim
ne mange plus ça me faisait grossir
j'ai arrêté à temps non c'est pour le
plaisir d'en faire ou dans le free
rejeter des crêpes par exemple pas
n'importe quel crêpes whaou
si vous voulez de l'inédit une
découverte plus j'ai fait à la gloire du
fln à la foire du frotte la fph et el
juli co2 mazel qui arrive maintenant
dans le bois des pistes dans le pain a
dit dans le pain dépit d'une bonne base
et de saluer peut-être marcher sur la
marchande aurait coûté je passe les
détails
j'arrive aux proportions alors là c'est
très simple retenez 3,3 points comme les
trois de gibraltar
ça veut dire que 300 tonnes 300 g de
farine point car deux lignes d'eau 3e et
3 cuillères à beurre de bouche produits
nettoie 3.93 ou de nuit là
comme ça je n'ai même pas cherché de
l'été gersois gagner alors je défais
marc alyn jeu délai marafiq ma farine
peau à peau dans l'eau peu à peu dans do
peu peu à peu dans dans du lait ses
meilleurs dans du lait je les mange
tient déjà je mélange mélange jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'épaisseur de pateras produits
de pâtes
ashley greene naturellement j'ai mis ma
poêle à chauffer sur le poil sur le gaz
si vous avez d'électricité et dans la
poêle et chaude une goutte d'huile
naturellement et une mais une seule
cuillère à garou de patrick hierard
agathe des arts à vous une petite louche
peu ordinaire pas plus c'est une manie
en france de vouloir faire les crêpes
trois points tombent et s pour un soin
trophée présent les très petits pin
bordel quoi ni bruges
ah j'oubliais c'est à ce moment là que
vous connaissiez tomber en pluie
quelques grains de riz cadre aux aides
en nature des réseaux brocade sous la
main des prix ou des fruits confits si
vous n'arrivez pas à retrouver les
raisins mais alors h et fréthun achète
et le moment venu
vous prenez alors comme ceux ci la queue
de la poêle quoi voilà le manche était
gentil vous ne regardiez semer revenu
tout de suite
et hop alors ça c'est rien du tout à
faire il faut pas se laisser distraire
d'un coup sec du poignet voulant chez v2
vous lâchez la toile et barbaste la
crêpe
vous lancez couleurs nuancées lune vous
gâcher l'autre est pendant et oui c'est
vrai avez vous encore en place et la
pâte vous massacrer la foule de la place
d'ailleurs maintenant quand je fais des
crêpes
ma femme me laisse toute la cuisine
maudit comprend avec toi on ne connaît
pas les points de chute
elle est gentille non parce que une fois
je l'avais laissé tomber ma crêpe par ma
femme je les ramasse et était pas cassé
je leur mise bien à poil ma femme ma foi
non alors comme je l'avais une bonne
cinquantaine les mettre à refroidir dans
un moule rond comme les traites quand
elles sont réussies les recouvrir de
mort vers l'inde de marc mal de purée de
fruits puisque c'est le but de la tête
voyez c'est à la portée d'un enfant et
vous mettez l'enfant au four lentement
au four moment de servir ajoutez un peu
de choses sucrées et c'est tout mais
retenez le nom céder ni lin caisse ni
des câliner sni denis launay ce qui
défie saleh c'est un mot polonais
enfin ces décrets tu mets des crêpes à
la confiture c'est ça l'originalité des
crêpes à la fourniture à la fin elle a
défait ben moi je mets le chocolat et
c'est aussi beau bref vous si vous
n'avez pas chaude à mettet de la con qui
dure coucou
[Musique]